[موسيقى]
اذا اصبريت نتعرف على اليوم الاول في كاس
العالم فرنسا
تحركات مواجهتها حاله من سوء الرقابه
الشديد من جانب دفاع المنتخب القطري اللي
كانوا مسؤولين عن توصيل الكره لفالنسيا
هما اثنين كاسيدو ومندس ولهاني لاعبين
الارتكاز او وانتم بالفضل اللي موجود عن
المنتخب
اللاعبين كانوا يساهموا بخروج الكره بشكل
ممتاز جدا ويوصلوها عن طريق الكرات عرضيه
لاينر فالنسيا اللي قدر عن طريق واحده من
هذه الكرات انه ياخذ ركله جزاء ويسجله
شخصيا لا يعلن عن الهدف الاول في كاس
العالم 2022 في قطر اضف الى ذلك منتخب
اليك ودور كان رائع بعمليه المسانده من
قبل اظهره الاستبيانكا ممتاز واللاعب اللي
كان موجود لشبهك وادراسه بالمناسبه على
الجهه اليمنى كان ايضا ممتاز وبالتالي كان
في كرات ارضيه عم تلعب بشكل جيد وواحده
منها
منها الهدف الثاني وكانت من تمريره متايدو
للاعب الظهير الايمن اللي رفعها الفالنسيا
وفالنسيا كان قادر يسجل هدف الثاني لذلك
منتخب الاكوادور قدم شوط اول مثالي وهذا
اسبابه هي التالي انه مدرب منتخب
الاكوادور وضع الضغط قبل المباراه على
المنتخب القطري وشاف اصغر المنتخب القطري
هو المرشح لتحقيق الفوز في هذه المباراه
وبالتالي مع ضغط الجماهير مع ضغط الافتتاح
وضعه اضافي على المنتخب القطري وحررت
فريقك بشكل كامل من هذه الضغوطات الشعب
الثاني هو خبره لاعبين المنتخب
الاكوادور عند الخبره طويله بيكون العالم
لانه منتخب متمرس منتخب صلوا زمان بيشارك
في البطولات وفي عنده لعيبه مشاركه كاس
العالم سابقا مثل فالنسيا اللي بيقدر يؤثر
على اللاعبين بشكل جيد وده من جيز ايضا
ايضا اكثر بشكل ممتاز على عقليه لاعبين
وعلى التحضير الذهني مثل هذه المباريات
طبعا هاي العوامل
افتقدها المنتخب القطري الى انه منتخب قطر
كان داخل خايف شويه متوتر لانه عليه الضغط
طبعا وبالتالي كانت البدايه صعبه جدا تلقى
فيها هدف مبكر الغاء الحكم بعد ذلك وهذا
كان شئ اجابه للمنتخب القطري ولكن وبعد
ذلك تلقى هدف اثنين وهاي الى اسباب عديده
السلام الاول هو مثل ما حكينا سوء رقابه
اخوكي ابو علام وعبد الكريم حسن على
الشباب الثاني هو عدم قدره لاعبيه خط
الوسط وهنا عم بحكي عن كريم ضيافه عبد
العزيز حاتم على حمايه الدفاع القطري من
الهجمات الاكوادوريه لمسه الاولى للمنتخب
قطر كانت سيئه جدا يعني الكنترول الاول
على الكره كان سي وهو الامر اللي ساهم
بشكل كبير لانه لاعبين الاكوادور ويخط
الكره ويروحوا بيها شمال مباشره
على الامر اكثر بشكل كبير لانه الدفاع
القطري ما بيكون جاهز هاي الحالب
وبتروح على المرتد وبالتالي بتصير الامور
صعبه جدا على الدفاع عنه يتعامل مع الهجمه
الاكوادوريه السبب الاخر لازم نحكي عنه هو
سوء مسانده الاظهره او الوينج باكس كونه
قطر كانت عم تلعب 52 فوجدرو ووجود همام
على الجهه اليمنى واليسرى ما كان قادر
يقدم اي اضافه لهجوم القطري لذلك ما شفنا
اي هجمه خطيره خطيره الشوط الاول باستثناء
الكره اللي اتصرف فيها حسن الهدوس على
الجهه اليمنى وارسل كره عرضيه للمعز علي
بنهايه الشوط وضيعها طبعا بطريقه غريبه
جدا لذلك نحن عم نحكي عن انه المنتخب
القطري يفتقد للخبره للمشاركه بكاس العالم
يفتقد للادوات اللي قادره تخليه يظهر
بعيدا في هذه البطوله حسب ما شفنا على
الاقل بالمباراه الاولى من كاس العالم
2022 على فلكس سانشيز انه يشتغل اكثر على
عمليه الخروج بالكره على دهنيه اللاعبين
وبكل امانه منتخب قطر لديه الادوات
الهجوميه ولكن دفاعيا وفي وسط الملعب
اموره شوي صعبه حتى سعد الشيب يعني عندي
عتب على سعد الشيف لانه اداء اليوم ما كان
ثابت ما كان قادر انه يتعامل مع الهجمات
الكويتريه بالشكل الصحيح والتايمنج تبعه
بالخروج
منتخب بلاده ركله جزاء بالحديث عن الشوط
الثاني الشوط الثاني
اثنين صفر مش محتاج اني هاجم مش محتاج
يطلع من المناطقي بلعب دفاع وسكر بشكل
اللازم وسلم
في ايضا علامه استفهام على تاخر في
الاكستان الاجراءات اول تبديل كان دقيقتين
تقريبا
وبالتالي متاخر جدا على فريق خسران 2-0
لدرجه انه منتخب الاكوادور بدل قبل منتخب
قطر في هذه المباراه
فعمليه التاخر بالتبديلات ايضا اثرت بشكل
كبير على منتخب القطري الاكوادور استحقت
الفوز في هذه المباراه جمهورها قاره رائعه
وجمهور قطر ايضا كان رائع حفل الافتتاح
كان جيد جدا التنظيم كان ممتاز مثل ما
حكينا قال بدايه المباراه المباراه
الثانيه
اصعب للمنتخب القطري في هذه البطوله مهما
كان وضع المنتخب القطري لن يقدم اداء اسوا
من اللي قدم اليوم لانه طبعا مثل ما حكينا
هي مباراه الكتاب في ضغط وما الى ذلك من
امور ذلك اتوقع انه المنتخب القطري يقدم
اداء افضل امام السنغال وهولندا المباراه
الان هذه المجموعه انتهت اول المباراه
الاولى من هذه المجموعه انتهت بفوز الان
متصدره قطر متغيره في المجموعه وعنا
هولندا والسنغال راح يلعب بكره راح نشوف
شو راح يصير في مباراه ونشوف على شو راح
ترسا هذه النتيجه وقد ايش راح تخلص لنشوف
كيف راح يكون ترتيب المجموعه مع نهايه
الجوله الاولى توقعات الشخصيه اتوقع انه
من هذه المجموعه هولندا والاكوادور اللي
راح يعدوا للدور الثاني الا اذا قطر
والسنغال كان عندهم رايه اخر في قادم
المباريات